FROM >> THE FINAL ELECTION OF
THE 2022 SET --
RAPHAEL WARNOCK FACING OFF
AGAINST REPUBLICAN CHALLENGER
HERSCHEL WALKER IN TODAY'S, OR
TUESDAY'S RUNOFFS, I SHOULD SAY,
WE SEE RECORD TURNOUT IN EARLY
VOTING WITH MORE THAN 1.8
MILLION GEORGIANS CASTING
BALLOTS ALREADY.
DIANE GALLAGHER IS IN ATLANTA
FOR US.
DIANE, WHAT ARE WARNOCK AND
WALKER DOING IN THE FINAL DAYS
OF THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL?
I HAD TO SAY IT'S A SPRINT TO
THE FINISH.
>> YEAH, IT'S LITERALLY THE
FINAL HOME STRETCH HERE FOR
THIS RUNOFF ELECTION.
SO, IT MAY BE AS NOT AS BUSY AS
YOU THOUGHT IT WOULD BE FOR
BOTH CANDIDATES.
I WOULD SAY THE INCUMBENT
SENATOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK HOLDING
SEVERAL EVENTS TODAY, IN
ATLANTA, IN AUGUSTA, GEORGIA.
AND ALSO SEVERAL TOMORROW AS
WELL.
HE IS TRADITIONALLY KEPT A MUCH
MORE AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULE THAN
HIS OPPONENT.
REPUBLICAN HERSCHEL WALKER,
HERSCHEL WALKER DOES NOT HAVE
ANY PUBLIC EVENTS THAT ARE OPEN
TO THE PRESS LISTED TODAY.
THIS SATURDAY BEFORE ELECTION
DAY.
HE DOES HAVE AN EVENT ON HIS
SCHEDULE TOMORROW IN LOGANVILLE,
GEORGIA.
BUT LOOK, THE WALKER CAMPAIGN
HAS TYPICALLY HAD A MORE
RELAXED CAMPAIGN SCHEDULE THAN
THE WARNOCK CAMPAIGN HAS.
ACROSS THIS ENTIRE FOUR-WEEK
RUNOFF PERIOD.
THAT IS EVEN DURING THE EARLY
VOTING PERIOD THAT JUST ENDED
ON FRIDAY.
YOU MENTIONED MORE THAN 1.8 5
MILLION GEORGIANS HAVE ALREADY
CAST THEIR BALLOT.
THEY HAD A SINGLE DAY VOTING
RECORD YESTERDAY, ON FRIDAY,
WITH MORE THAN 350,000 VOTES.
THAT DAY, THAT BEAT MONDAY AND
TUESDAY WHICH ALSO SET RECORDS
THEMSELVES JIM, I SHOULD
MENTION THAT WHILE WE ARE
SETTING SINGLE DAILY RECORD IT
LOOKS AS IF THEY ARE GOING TO
MISS, WELL, THEY ARE GOING TO
MISS THE EARLY VOTE THRESHOLD
THAT WAS SET IN THE 2021
RUNOFF.
OF COURSE, THAT WAS AFTER THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, THERE
WERE TWO SENATE RACES THEN.
PART OF THAT WAS BECAUSE OF THE
COMPRESSED FOUR-WEEK SCHEDULE
WITH FIVE MANDATED DAYS OF
EARLY VOTING INSTEAD OF THREE
WEEKS.
>> ALL RIGHT, VERY GOOD, A LOT
ON THE LINE, OF COURSE, DIANE
GALLAGHER, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
WE APPRECIATE IT.
JOINING ME NOW, THIS IS
REPUBLICAN STRATEGIST FOR RNC
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR DOUG
HIGH, AND DEMOCRATIC STRATEGIST
A DEEP.
DOUG, LET ME START WITH YOU,
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THAT
HERSCHEL WALKER DOES NOT
DESERVE TO BE IN THIS RACE.
GEORGIA LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND
JEFF DUNCAN REPUBLICAN, HE WAS
NOT HOLDING BACK, HE SAID HE
COULD BRING HIMSELF TO VOTE FOR
HERSCHEL WALKER.
BUT I WAS DOWN THERE IN ATLANTA
ONE MONTH AGO, THIS IS WHAT
GEORGIA REPUBLICANS WERE
SAYING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE GOP
SHOULD LEARN FROM THIS RUNOFF.
THIS IS SENATE RACE?
>> WHAT WE SHOULD LEARN FROM
THE ENTIRE ELECTIONS FROM THE
LAST MONTH, MITCH MCCONNELL IS
RIGHT, CANDIDATE QUALITY
MATTERS.
IN CAMPAIGNS AND IN FOOTBALL,
TIME OF POSSESSION IS
IMPORTANT.
HERSCHEL WALKER KNOWS THAT MORE
THAN ANYBODY.
HE HAS BEEN ON DEFENSE.
HE HAS NOT BEEN ON OFFENSE
EVERY DAY OF THIS RUNOFF HE HAS
BEEN ON DEFENSE HE STRUGGLED
WITH ANY KIND OF QUALITY
MESSAGE.
HE IS NOT GETTING GOOD NEWS OUT
THERE.
HE SAYS BIZARRE THINGS.
BIZARRE IS ACTUALLY A KIND WAY
TO PUT IT.
WARNOCK IS IN THE DRIVER SEAT
HERE IT IS WHY MITCH MCCONNELL,
WHEN WE WRITE THE AUTOPSY, THE
RNC IS LOOKING AT THIS NOW, OF
WHAT WENT WRONG IN 2022.
QUALITY OF CANDIDATES IS TOP OF
THE LIST.
>> ALL RIGHT, KEEP, LET ME TURN
TO YOU, VAN JONES HAS CALLED
THIS A DECISION BETWEEN THE
PRIDE AND THE COMMUNITY AND THE
SHAME OF A COMMUNITY.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN THIS RUNOFF
BETWEEN THESE TWO CANDIDATES?
>> I THINK HE IS RIGHT, JIM.
I DON'T KNOW ANYONE IN GEORGIA,
OR ANYWHERE ELSE, HONESTLY, WHO
SERIOUSLY THINK THAT HERSCHEL
WALKER, FROM TEXAS, IS
QUALIFIED IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATOR FROM GEORGIA.
NEVER MIND THE FACT THAT HE
DOES NOT HAVE LIVED IN THE
STATE, AND HAS NOT VOTED IN THE
STATE, BUT CLEARLY, HE HAS NO
EXPERIENCE, NO PREPARATION, NO
KNOWLEDGE TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ON
THIS JOB.
HE IS GOING AGAINST SOMEONE
LIKE RAPHAEL WARNOCK, WHO'S AN
EXPERIENCED LEGISLATOR, HE HAS
WORKED IN THE COMMUNITY, HE IS
VOTED IN THE COMMUNITY.
PEOPLE CAN SEE THE DIFFERENCE.
AT THIS POINT, IT'S NOT A
QUESTION ABOUT PERSUASION, IT'S
ABOUT TURN OUT.
ANYTHING CAN HAPPEN IN THIS
ELECTION.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS ON PREVIOUS
ELECTIONS IN THE PAST.
IT'S JUST A QUESTION OF WHICH
CAMPAIGN CAN GET OUT ITS VOTERS
TO THE POLLS THROUGH THE EARLY
VOTING ALL THE WAY TO TUESDAY.
>> DOUG, THEN THERE WAS THIS
MOMENT, FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK
OBAMA SEES AN UNUSUAL REMARK
FROM HERSCHEL WALKER ABOUT --
>> I DON'T KNOW IF YOU KNOW --
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING I
FOUND OUT, TO KILL A VAMPIRE,
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
I NEVER KNEW THAT, I DON'T WANT
TO BE A VAMPIRE ANYMORE, I WANT
TO BE A WEREWOLF.
>> THIS HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
ISSUES THAT ARE OF GREAT
IMPORTANCE TO THE PEOPLE OF
GEORGIA.
LIKE WHETHER IT'S BETTER TO BE
A VAMPIRE OR A WEREWOLF.
THIS IS A DEBATE, AND I MUST
CONFESS, I ONCE HAD MYSELF.
WHEN I WAS SEVEN.
[LAUGHTER] THEN I GREW UP.
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED, HE CAN
BE ANYTHING HE WANTS TO BE,
EXCEPT FOR A UNITED STATES
SENATOR.
>> DOUG, YOUR THOUGHTS.
WEREWOLF, VAMPIRE?
WHICH IS WORSE?
>> SENATE IS WORSE.
--
>> PLENTY OF BOTH.
>> THIS IS WHAT MCCONNELL WAS
TALKING ABOUT.
HE WAS SORT OF FORCED TO GO
ALONG WITH HERSCHEL WALKER.
HE WAS CLEARLY GOING TO BE THE
NOMINEE OF GEORGIA, OTHER
CANDIDATES, IT WAS NOT CLEAR IF
DR. OZ IS GOING TO WIN AND SO
FORTH.
THIS IS WHAT MCCONNELL WARNED
ABOUT, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
WEREWOLVES AND VAMPIRES, THINGS
LIKE THAT.
THIS IS NOT NORMAL STUFF, THIS
IS THE LESSON THAT REPUBLICANS
NEED TO LEARN.
THE LAST FIVE YEARS, WHENEVER
YOU THINK ABOUT DONALD TRUMP'S
POLICIES, THE LAST FIVE YEARS,
REPUBLICANS HAD THE ATOMS
FAMILY, A RUNNING OF RACE AFTER
RACE, WHETHER IT'S PRESIDENT,
SENATE, CONGRESS, YOU LOOK AT
MADISON IN NORTH CAROLINA.
YOU NEED TO TURN AWAY FROM
THESE CANDIDATES, GET TO
SERIOUS LEGISLATORS, AND THEN
GEORGIA WILL BE RUNNING AGAIN.
>> THEY MIGHT START WINNING
SOME RACES, GO FIGURE.
>> CLOSE CONTEST.
KEITH, LET ME ASK YOU THIS, I
THINK THIS IS ON A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT --
A FASCINATING DEVELOPMENT,
DEMOCRATS MOVING FORWARD WITH
AS PRESIDENT BIDEN'S BEFORE
POOL OF MAKING SOUTH CAROLINA
THAT FIRST DATE TO HOLD A
PRIMARY.
SOMEONE WHO COVERED A LOT OF
PRESIDENTIAL RACES ALL THE WAY
TO 2004.
WE CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE, AS
CAMPAIGN REPORTERS, WE WOULD
LIKE TO START COVERING THESE
RACES AT A WARM CLIMATE LIKE
SOUTH CAROLINA, IF I COULD
SPEAK SELFISHLY FOR MY FELLOW
POLITICAL FORCE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
IS THAT A GOOD IDEA?
>> I HAVE A SIMILAR BIAS THAT
YOU DO, JIM.
I WANT TO CALL AT DARTMOUTH
COLLEGE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE.
I COVERED THE 1984 PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN AS A STUDENT REPORTER.
WORKED --
>> YOU ARE NOT THAT OLD.
[LAUGHTER] >> I DON'T WANT TO
GO BACK TO NEW HAMPSHIRE OR
IOWA FOR THAT MATTER, AND SOUTH
CAROLINA, HONESTLY, IS A MUCH
POORLY REPRESENT IS A STATE FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THE MAJORITY OF THE VOTERS FOR
SOUTH CAROLINA ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IN TERMS OF LOYAL
SUPPORTERS ARE AFRICAN
AMERICANS AS WELL.
PRESIDENT BIDEN WON HIS FIRST
PRIMARY IN THE SOUTH CAROLINA
PRIMARY AT 2020.
I THINK IT'S A RETURN OF THE
FAVOR, IF YOU WILL.
IT'S ALTON IMPORTANT STATEMENT
ABOUT THE AMERICAN PARTY.
IT'S ALSO NEVADA, MICHIGAN IN
THE LINEUP AS WELL.
I AM NOT SURE OF ALL OF THE
STATES --
BECAUSE OF IOWA, NEW HAMPSHIRE.
FIRST IN THE NATION.
I THINK IT IS TIME, IT IS LONG
PAST TIME.
OUR COUNTRY IS MORE DIVERSE.
AND AND IT IS MUCH MORE DIVERSE
THAN IOWA AND NEW HAMPSHIRE.
IT'S TIME TO HAVE A PRIMARY
SCHEDULE THAT ALIGNS WITH THE
INTEREST OF THE PEOPLE THAT
ELECT OUR LEADERS.
I THINK IT'S TIME.
LET ME VERY QUICKLY --
IS KEVIN MCCARTHY GOING TO GET
THE VOTES TO BECOME SPEAKER?
>> THAT IS THE MILLION DOLLAR
QUESTION.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT IS THE
MOST LIKELY, BUT WE DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S A 59 OR 41% CHANCE.
HIS JOB IS TO GO OUT AND GET
THOSE VOTES RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS WHY THE NEXT MONTH IS
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT.
>> IS THERE A PLAN B?
>> NO.
THAT IS HIS BEST OPTION RIGHT
NOW.
THERE IS NO PLAN B.
>> THAT ACTUALLY HEL